no eating it worth it as a whole new  series set in the UK we're gonna travel  glorious Britain try three different  fantastic foods at drastically different  price points four pounds fifty pounds  110 pounds 925 pound people sure you get  me the kebab here you're intoxicated and  we are about to enjoy kebab and this guy  Joe like that one and together will  determine which is the most worthy the  most exclusive dish on our menu Safran  puta really it's such a riot of flavor  black cod fried in panko oh bugger beef  made only in Japan hold on my bro  the vintage teeth really dries out your  mouth is slurping again there's a small  spoon of caviar drop 10 pounds worth he  can't even tell me that's his secret  good cop  you